la macabre découverte a eu lieu ici il y
a quinze ans dans la maison familiale
au petit matin la mère de grégory tombe
sur le corps de son fils gisant dans une
mare de sang
les médecins légistes remarque 19 plaies
par armes blanches localisés dans son
dos mais l'agresseur n'a jamais été
identifié quinze ans après les faits la
justice relance l'enquète elle va
procéder à de nouvelles investigations
nous avons décidé de faire analyser tout
un tas de prélèvement de d'objets placés
sous scellés qui n'avait pas été
analysées à ce jour ou qui l'avaient été
avec des techniques anciennes
et comme on sait qu'en la matière la
science évolue très vite
nous avons décidé de faire à nouveau ses
investigations biologiques technique
pour voir s'il n'y avait pas des
éléments nouveaux à utiliser des cheveux
des poils des vêtements et plusieurs
objets prélevés sur la scène du crime
vont ainsi être analysés dans un
laboratoire des micro traces d adn
peuvent aujourd'hui parler mais un appel
à témoins est également lancée peut-être
que des personnes qui ont vu ou entendu
des choses à l'époque qui n'ont pas
estimé utile d'en parler nous pensons
que c'était pas forcément important si
aujourd'hui des éléments leur reviennent
en mémoire bien évidemment il faut
qu'ils contactent les services de police
parce que il n'ya pas de témoignages
anodin et quelquefois c'est avec des
petites pièces de puzzle bien évidemment
qu'on peut arriver à trouver quelque
chose et à trouver des éléments qui nous
permettront de mettre un nom sur sur
l'agresseur est celui qui a qui a tué se
nomme les membres de l'entourage de
grégory labbé pourrait également être
entendu par la justice prochainement les
résultats seront connus début 2017 au
plus tôt en revanche si ces analyses ne
donne rien il existe encore un délai de
prescription de dix ans pour que de
nouveaux témoins relance l'enquète